[Music]
so listen no matter who you are at some
point of your life you're gonna make a
decision you're going to regret
everybody at some point goes through
this it could be when we were little
kids
and you take that paperclip and you put
it in the electrical socket and then
afterwards your hair gets crazy and you
get that shot for the first time I
remember I was in the army one time
working as a Hummer mechanic and I was
underneath the Hummer and I put this
wrench in and it touches the starters
tip and another electrical base that
they had I was shocked so hard I mean I
will forever remember that moment
because I felt like I was I thought the
jolt in my entire body right that was a
regret sometimes you feel regrets with
relationships you dated a girl you knew
you should never date in the first place
or a guy no matter what it is there's
regrets and so the way in life if you
were to look at that with business the
way it works in business the more you
can minimize decisions you make that you
regret afterwards the higher of a chance
you give yourself to make it in business
so today I'm gonna dissect the entire
process of making a decision how to make
the best decision and then how to go
back and engage yourself and say am I
making the right decision most of the
time before I get into it any questions
any thoughts any comments comment on the
bottom as I'm going through this we are
gonna have a PDF at the end so stick
around for the free PDF that you'll get
and last but not least if you haven't
subscribed to this channel click on the
subscribe button to subscribe and join a
notification squad by click on the alert
button right next to so let's get right
into a look in a world of business
you're gonna make decisions but the
decisions are typically going to come
down to two different types of decisions
you'll make let me explain one is
offense one is defense let me explain
offense is sales marketing expansion
growth recruiting hiring technology
everything is offense offense oftens
we're growing the company so you're
making a decision if we buy this this
could help the company grow if we hire
this person this can make the company go
to the next level on the other side
decisions that you make and investments
that you make is defense what does this
mean you have two choices on getting an
attorney one attorney is $300 an hour
one attorney is eighty one hundred eight
hundred dollars an hour this attorney
gives you a 50% chance of winning this
attorney gives you an 80% chance of
winning
the cost difference is $500 per hour but
the chances of this guy helping yet is
30% more that is a defensive decision
that you got to make another one could
be compliance you make a certain
decision so it prevents the company from
getting complaints or lawsuits or all
this other stuff that is defensive this
is not necessarily going to give you
high returns this gives you a lifespan
of sticking around the business those
are two things you're looking at as you
go through offense defense having said
that let's go through the step process
of what happens when you make a decision
together step number one what issue will
this solve if you make this decision
today what is it gonna solve what
problem you're facing today that it's
gonna solve what what investment what
growth what is that opportunity it's
gonna solve for you the second thing I
to think about what questions you ask is
how urgent is this issue I think
sometimes entrepreneurs they treat
everything as life and death if you
treat everything as life and that it's
kind of like being in a relationship and
everything you do your girlfriend says
that's it we got to break up this is not
gonna work out that's it we gotta break
up this is not gonna work out not
everything in business is life or death
but you got to be able to know we have
to address this issue if it's compliance
it's a now-or-never we're going to be
out of business because our partners or
vendors gonna pull out it's very
important so as you're going through it
the first thing I ask are those two
things okay
first two things what are we gonna solve
how urgent is it now let's set those two
things aside I might give you a PDF to
go through this whatever issue you are
dealing with I want you to think about
this acronym it's very easy B T our D
stands for dollar T stands for time our
stands for return let me explain dollar
how much is it going to cost you it's
gonna cost me $50,000 it's gonna cost me
$10,000 it's gonna cost me $100,000
great - how much time is it going to
take to address this opportunity or
problem well if I spend this $50,000
it's gonna take four weeks until we have
this technology out so can help us
improve our systems which will help us
make more sales great if I spend this
$50,000 it's gonna bring me this
technology that's gonna prevent us from
getting complaints but it's gonna take
us eight weeks to get this up and eight
weeks from now it'll be fixed phenomenal
and last but not least return
what type of return am I gonna make on
this money and this time that I'm
committing to this project you got to
look at those three things the DTR after
you know how urgent the issue is and
after you know what issue this decision
you're gonna make
is gonna solve once you have those
things okay the DTR and those two
questions you ask at first then it's the
last thing but at this point sometimes
you'll sit there and you'll say oh my
gosh this thing's gonna make us a
millionaire we have to get it right now
had a guy that called me and it said Pat
I see this you know amazing virtual
reality technology that if we get it's
gonna be phenomenal as a startup it's
gonna be phenomenal it's gonna help me
be like nobody else at the restaurants
and all this other stuff and imagine if
you're sitting there and the menus are
gonna be all this other stuff I said
that's great
it sounds exciting how much of that
money are you gonna put he says what's
gonna cost me thirty five thousand
dollars how much do you have right now
forty thousand dollars you need to tell
me about to spend ninety percent your
money into this one project that you
don't know nothing on it's gonna do yes
listen we got it set that part aside
here's why because the last thing you
got to think about as you're going
through these things is blind spots are
there any blind spots and by the way
typically you will never see the blind
spots here's why let me explain what I
mean by this how often have you had a
friend okay date a girl well you look at
from the outset and you're like dude I
don't know why this guy's dating this
girl this is not gonna work out I don't
know why this guy and this girl are
together there's no way in the world
this is gonna work out right how often
have you seen that where you see from
the outside you know too much
information about her or him you know
it's not gonna work yet but he's got
blind spots you know why he's got blind
spots because he's in love and he
doesn't see the blind spots
typically blind spots are the reason why
people have advisors they have Board of
Directors they have an advisory board
because the advisory board can help you
say hey Johnny I'm sorry I hate to say
this I don't mean to burst your bubble
you got a blind spot here buddy you put
this money here you gonna put this much
of it you don't know necessarily we're
gonna make the return on your money
sounds like you're pretty excited babe
because it's different everybody else
and all you want to do is be different
versus the other guy used to be a part
of in this other company no no no no
don't do that you're making a decision
emotionally no need to do this maybe
you're from now maybe to you
from now but not right now that's why
entrepreneurs get advisors and board of
directors so as you have that process
that's your you know platform you're
looking at right your your frame as
you're making decisions then comes the
other side which is gauging how often
you make the right decision let me
explain to you what I mean by this
here's the first thing you got to think
about when it comes down to gauging
yourself on how often you make the right
decisions out of the last ten decisions
that you made how much time that the
wrong decisions take you away from the
business the reason why I shared this is
because it's like I remember when I was
done dating just to date and waste my
time and I told a girl I'll never forget
this I said I am done dating somebody
and just getting comfortable with you
after six months knowing we will never
be together it's just not gonna happen
you know what I know this is just never
gonna work out I'm done doing that the
same goes with business where you get to
a point where you say I'm done making
wasted decisions and investments because
it's taking time away from my core
strengths that if I focus on my core
strengths we grow the company forget
about the millions of dollars I've lost
it's the weeks that you lose or the
hours that you lose or the months that
you lose that if you had those back and
you focus on your core what would happen
to the business now let me say this last
part before some of you are feeling like
crap while you're watching this because
in shitman I've made so many bad
decisions I don't feel good about myself
right now look no one starts off being
an 80% free-throw shooter nobody no one
starts off being a 50% free-throw
shooter
you're now insane it is everybody starts
off being a 0% free-throw shooter
no one starts off shooting their basket
and they're all you know I'm good I make
you know that no we are terrible when we
first take a shot as a kid and then you
get better at it the same thing goes
with decision making process but the
challenge is it took me a decade to come
out with a format to measure the right
decisions versus the bad decisions you
have access to this process now go
download the PDF which is below it's on
the website Patra by David Campbell
you'll see the link below download the
PDF Mauri I think it's a front and back
right that they have it explains the
whole thing with you where you'll be
able to look at and say what issue will
dissolve how
this issue the DTR dollar time returned
the blind spots that I have the 10 last
decisions that I made all those things
is formatted there and then started
measuring your own decisions and the
next time you're about to make a back
big decision
pull this PDF out or watch this video
and say boom nope we're not gonna be
doing this because it's not not that
urgent yes we're gonna be doing this
because it's life-or-death the DTR
formula you write down on a board and
say 50 grand six weeks seventeen percent
we should do it phenomenal and everybody
buys into because you have an argument
to make where your boards gonna say I
like the decision you're making Johnny
I like the decision you're making Mary
let's move forward this decision that
we're making here so having said that
now you got a way to measure your this
is your making process any questions
thoughts comments you got comment on the
bottom and again if you haven't yet
subscribed to the channel click on the
sub button and join the notification
squad by clicking on the alert button
right next to take everybody bye-bye